fireboy creative asks Gary I'm a big fan
of online courses I see this you surfing
traditional institutions of Education in
a big way do you see this happening and
is there money to be made what's up fire
boy no quick answer to this question is
yes you know yes like you know uber
Airbnb Skillshare it's probably one of
the ones you're talking about there's a
bunch out chase jarvis is behind one um
yes like I absolutely believe Khan
Academy the fact that when I'm trying to
learn something I go to youtube and
search a how-to and watch a one-minute
how-to video like information as
education is a commodity the Internet
has created that platform for us to
learn that way I don't need a teacher as
charismatic as they may be to just tell
me the information what what matters our
opinions interpretations contacts not
the base information and so even hear my
base information is fine how i layer the
context of the current world is far more
interesting and so I think education is
massively going to be disrupted over the
next 20 years and I think you're barking
up the right tree oh crap wait subscribe
do I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe